I never chosen music the music chose me
right damn that's deepest but you know
what I'm talking about you like when
music chooses you know I was
um
[Music]
you're just now dropping into the middle
of a new careful Boys episode David so
is an hour today
it's [__] lit in here right now dude
what song is that you got it you got it
specific
songs that changed our lives
let me tell you something man I [__]
love music dude me too hey can we talk
about that scissors album real quick
though that's his album is [__] fire
that's like something that everybody has
been waiting to drop for a hot second
forever forever and it was worth the
[__] it was so good it's not good
it's so interesting right because like
with music now
um if you guys have if you guys do go to
like live concerts and stuff one of the
biggest disappointments that I ever had
was going to these live concerts and
finding out that monthly these
[__] can't sink yeah oh who
that happened with there's a lot of
people like that I like Jason Chen
could actually sing really really well
he just seems About Soul
that was seems like a [__] robot dude
but like technically he has some of the
best breath control I've ever heard in
my life so if you look at his vocal
tracks all of his waves are even so
whenever he belts whenever he like
controls his voice he can control it so
[__] well it's unreal but it just
sounds like there's no soul behind it
did I drink too much I think he might be
singing because he's thinking about the
accents
you [__]
you can do like we'll record a track hey
I want to do a cover with you right
which I'm like all right just that guess
right it was hey can you do your runs
and I'll copy your runs and I'm like
you're the musician
a comedian you set the set the music
dude and this will just waiting
can you do it again for me so I can copy
it like how are you gonna cover a song
and then cover my cover
the professional coverer dude sweet
little all right sausage changed her
life uh how about we start uh with an
era so we all error or theme ooh either
okay just something that we can like all
play in that realm because there's so
many [__] Realms yeah uh jams that
you would always listen to in your car
um
okay
um this is almost a whole album but
there's specific songs in it uh did you
guys ever have the street jams CDs oh
Street jams I don't even know people
know that [__] it's like the best of the
best uh [__] Power 106 music Africa
bambata like Planet Rock
play at your own risk looking for the
perfect beat but yeah Planet Rock okay
Africa changed my life still yeah I was
trying to find uh these albums at the
car washes for the longest time because
by the time I was looking for them they
didn't even carry their music stores
because they weren't popular so you had
to get them out car washes like where
the low rider hits were yeah yeah yeah
yeah next to the girls yeah
right and then in there there was uh so
Planet Rock by Africa Baba and soul
Sonic force was to me what I thought B
boys listened to so then I would
literally absorb it like I was getting
Powers
it wasn't
you take me to school it would be the
thing playing like as if I had a like a
show I was gonna do and I was memorizing
it for that but no it was it just drove
him crazy because he was like this is so
old he was actually like for me in high
school the [__] that I used to always
bang in my car or bump in my car was
always [__] Mac tray yeah dude that
is so NorCal so that's what I'm saying
so like but by the time time we were
[__] doing that it was like four
years later then it hit SoCal because
music wasn't yeah it was later yeah so
it would always be [__] first I do
like this I put a look on my face like I
smell sippist bounce to the beat till it
started but not that's not they're smart
off his shirt off me shirt I [__]
love mattress was that before ghost
riding is Ghost no that was why ghost
riding was happening oh it was I mean
the song goes right now exactly people
were doing it before it was like a Bay
Area type of thing but then it became
really popularized after then it got on
the news because people were crashing
cars all over the place yeah but my
grade was a catalyst bro it was so weird
because when I first listened to Max Ray
and there was like Andre nicotino there
was Keak the sneak there was all these
people we I don't understand what he's
saying
but I never it's like E40 yeah
[Laughter]
I never really [__] with it because
they always had like these janky-ass
Casio [__] keyboard [__]
citizenship for the tracks because it
was like oh this ain't [__] real
hip-hop but then for some reason it was
so [__] that's what made it though
dude I know it's like the pack Advanced
yeah so good this [__] has like two
notes
but it was a deep bass I used to crack
the [__] up because it was I'm not gonna
say her name but she was so [__] dumb
and I remember they had that song come
out go stupid right yeah so s t u p i d
when we go to the club we don't need ID
everywhere we go it's a party y'all we
don't get it cracking like a Smartie
glow right so we were we were at this
club and this girl's so [__] dumb she
didn't know how to spell stupid so she
goes
[Laughter]
up bro
I I paused I look and I was like trying
to hide her lips I was like wait what'd
you say though she was like I spelled it
I said no spell it right now right and
she's like but you [__] mean I'm like
DJ cuts the music yeah spell it
hey yo Club hold up turn on the lights
turn on the lights [__] what you said
dude
my first introduction to any of this
[__] so like I lived in the cul-de-sac
right and then my brothers and cousins
went over to the neighbor's house and
they would break dance in the garage so
my first time just witnessing that [__]
and then there was this one track it was
paper boy the Ditty
I was like what is this song and then my
cousin got me like a little or or the
neighbor someone got me a cassette tape
of that song and I [__] obsessively
played that [__] Non-Stop and
that was my first like fall in love Jam
well the strange thing about that song
is that it was a word of mouth track
because they didn't play that on the
radio oh really at the time yeah damn
not when it was like well I had the
cassette
yeah that's why you were lucky because
you just didn't hear it yeah and I just
over and over and over and over and then
the other one was um Warren G and Nate
Dogg regulator
and then those came in singles so there
was that in like a b side or something
but that was it you had one song and you
listened to that one song and you played
it over and over for like 10 hours
straight till your whole house was
annoyed of it you couldn't play songs
out back then no well that's the hard
part about music now is that you know
now it's about well is anything in news
in general right before you really sit
there and you get to realize or like
music like when people create a [__]
album right there's so much thought put
into it from the first track all the way
to the end nowadays like somebody will
review an album after a [__] like
three hours it's like how yeah yeah they
just want to be the first one to like
write about the company yeah you didn't
sit with this album before they would
give these people to uh people who would
have to review right they would sit with
it for like a month or two weeks because
it changes every day it changes the
first week you listen to it you're like
okay whatever and then about the last
week you're like oh my God bro I I used
to not like uh John Legend's album
revolver because he's flipped his sound
a little bit and John Legend is like one
of my biggest influences whatsoever
right and I didn't like it and then one
day my friend called me out he goes did
you listen the album from track from the
beginning to the end I was like no I
heard a couple I hate it he goes well
[__] go back and listen to it right I
listened it sat in my car listened to
the beginning to the end when I was
driving from uh North Carolina SoCal and
I [__] fell in love with the album
because I didn't give it a [__]
chance and so like the way that people
consume content in music is really
disappointing because they don't
understand like how much effort an
artist puts in their album right you'll
see now where uh my buddy Sue she's a
rapper he was talking about he went to
this one guy who's his son blew up on
Tick Tock right and he had a concert it
was packed out so these kids are arms
crossed talking while he's performing
his music until the tick tock song comes
on and then they're paying attention he
plays another song and they're just like
this talking through his whole set dang
and the guy was fed up he's like yo [__]
this [__] dude but that's how people are
consuming music like when we talk about
our love for music like we had to sit
there with these songs for a long time
right they don't consume it like we
because back then an LP right a full-on
album was a journey from intro to the
end that's why you had these stupid
tracks or skits in between that made
sense when you connect all the songs
together Eminem did that [__] for me oh
those skits in between
that was my album yeah Marshall Mathers
LP I remember [__] just listening to
that [__] story like what is this skit
and then obviously at that time too
you're like listening to the craziest
skits because yeah it's Eminem So you're
like this [__] time somebody
bagging them in the car like what the
[__] is he doing you know what I mean
but that was that was the [__] back then
I remember just loving every [__]
hate where you go by sequence and you
enjoyed that sequence yeah I know a song
I want to play when I [__] die dude
what is it what [__] Tupac dude life
dude how many brothers fell victim to
the street rest in peace
you know victim to these streets as I
build
when me and Hawkins we went skydiving in
Hawaii and they make you a video of your
Skydive they put that as his song on
this guy no way and he doesn't know we
don't know why what the [__] why would
you do that on a sky
Life Goes On
no there's like I don't know music it's
weird right because like I'll get a lot
of comments now like specifically the
patreon hey can you do a tutorial about
like how to sing properly or whatever
right the the hardest part about people
that they don't understand like singing
is so [__] complicated right uh
specifically like when you when you
you'll really start to understand if
anybody wants to do music out there
singing like casual like in a in a in a
bathroom where there's a lot of Reverb
covers up a lot of your mistakes when
you record on a mic all your mistakes
are so apparently it beats at you right
staring back at you so nowadays which is
why everybody sings in the shower
exactly so you have autotune and
melodyne the one thing that you can't
stray away from is live performances
yeah and then you hear it and it's the
worst experience ever because you can be
a producer can make you great but it
doesn't make you a great performer it
doesn't mean that you could really sing
while that's why I like acoustic
performances a lot yeah man and like
that's like as raw as it [__] there
are certain I've been liking all the
tiny desk ones dude they're so great
that's a Rite of Passage you've survived
that you're legit dude Mac Miller's tiny
desk every time I watch it raw oh man
hey you want to hear though yeah
no but like one of the things too like I
think a lot of like people don't
understand is like when you sing like
singing is so complicated to the point
where you have to understand what you're
seeing in order to make it sound really
good and do you feel it no that is a
really big thing that's a big thing it's
a story that you tell one of the best
devices that I ever had when I was like
First recording music is that they're
like okay what is the emotion that
you're trying to portray when you sing
right and there's a lot of like stuff
that comes after that with like breath
control right so for example if if
there's a lot of people who can hold a
note but they don't know how to put the
emphasis And the emotions in the right
place right so you can be in key which
is perfectly fine but how are you seeing
it and how are people going to feel yeah
Jason Chen you robot
I can't even defend himself here's a
great cover that a lot of people cover
even like young people right like a lot
of music Soul Child song oh yeah oh man
he's too good music Soul Child songs are
actually very very hard to cover and
they don't and I notice it every time
they cover it people are always a little
bit off-key because his stuff is very
very complicated like what's the what's
the typical uh music
oh that's another one because that key
change right or even something like just
friends right yeah right so how does
best friend start what's the beginning
this might seem strange but let me know
if I'm out of order for step into you
this way you see I've been watching you
for a while so go ahead take it take it
take it it was harmonizing
that's actually very very use I
guarantee you hear anybody cover that
song they're always a little they're off
a few notes every time because they
don't realize how complicated it is it's
he's always shifting Keys girl I've been
watching you for a while that's [__]
hard but to do that live right uh yeah
and while you're dancing
hahaha
it's like and getting it right
yeah you're not in your head and then
even harder because there's this crazy
keychain rough at the end I've been
trying to cover that song forever but
guaranteed every Filipino out there they
say you can cover it yes and it makes my
ears [__] bleed at the end because
that last keychain because it keeps
saying love
love is so many things isn't that a Thai
Dish
yeah
dang dude go ahead sing no that was oh
my God
he's aching to come out I gotta I gotta
give it a
the other shout out though because I did
mention Marshall Mathers LP when I say
Chronic 2001 was oh that's an Undisputed
he took a big Hiatus he was talking
about like albums you listen to in the
car I feel like in the car kind of 2001
for me was just that was pretty crazy
that's the nowadays everybody want to
talk about it
got it that's it the Vietnamese version
remix
I do remember when doggy style came out
oh Snoop Dogg and then it was you know I
never listened to that [__] with my
parents but my friend's parents they
were young so when Dave and then they
had subwoofers and [__] and then we
would go to the beach and then his dad
had like this Cutlass with [__] Rams
and [__] so it was like kind of like
Gangsta and then he leaned his chair
back we're all kids in the back seat
holding our towels like the [__] cars
rattling and I'm like this is [__]
who is that guy
it's funny
his mom's black right and it's a mixed
relationship his dad is white and he
looks like the geekiest white guy like
socks to his knees kind of like geeky
white guy and he used to work in in some
kind of film stuff like we used to pick
him I remember his mom were like we
would go pick up at like Fox Studios and
all these different Studios so I knew it
was like TV related but then so they was
hit they were cool yeah that is cool but
but this is hip-hop yeah this is hip-hop
you know but that's it was just like man
we're going to the beach we got the song
and then like we have the windows rolled
down and I was like this is so cool I
wish I was part of your family man my
parents my parents are whacked they're
doing Opera [__]
damn that's a crazy one because I got a
song I got a song that I bet you Ryan
can guess for mine can you guess right
changed your life yeah I got one wow
Yeah Daft Punk
really around the world you know what's
funny that's an honorable mention that's
not the one I was thinking all right is
Ed Sheeran I See Fire that's the one I
was thinking about yeah wait why that
one the hell what how does that one go
okay let me give me give you the origins
yeah that one's like oh I see five
um it was that the end of The Hobbit
I'll tell you I'll tell you where it
came from uh what most people know me
for I choreographed to it we ended up
doing it as the last performance on ABDC
it just had like a notoriety in that
space what it really like I I always
tell people who are like fans of my
dance and stuff like that that there was
like where do you get your music blah
blah how do you choose music and I'm
like the best routines I've ever created
the best anything I never chose the
music chose me you know what the [__]
you mean right damn that's deep as [__]
but you know what I'm talking about you
like when music choose you know I was
um
I know a song that chose me in high
school Ambitions as a writer like that
oh that's on fire that makes sense for
you though like that so I was
living at Alhambra at the time I was
right next to the [__] Alhambra
[__] uh movie theater and [__] like
that and uh The Hobbit desolation of
smog the second one had come out right
and me and my boy uh Rob we were like
hey dude let's take cubes like hey you
want to take some shrooms and I was like
okay so we took some shoes you want to
go watch The Hobbit it's like okay all
right there's something terribly stupid
about doing that okay because in The
Hobbit desolation of smog number one
the whole ending sequence is a giant
[__] Dragon that's [__] Chasing
The Hobbit you know what I mean it's
like dungey's buff like when you're on
shrooms usually you want to be like
happy and chill oh it's gonna you're not
trying to see a [__] Dragon like
coming at you so I'm like sitting there
we probably have 30 minutes of anxiety
that like nobody signed up
[Laughter]
sometimes to me the power in some like
shrooms is like the aftermath there's
like a Euphoria when like the anxiety
goes away if anybody knows what I'm
talking about right and so this whole
final climactic sequence of this dragon
is like [__] destroying everything
about our lives and then it like blacks
out to the credits right and the blacks
out so you're just like because you know
how like it's the second of three movies
so kind of like Cliffhanger right okay
guys and then out of nowhere Ed
Sheeran's voice is like
oh Mr and it's [__] beautiful oh it
starts with that part it starts right
there at the credits and I [__] you not
again when you're on you just got up and
started
bro this music this song comes on and
it's so it's so overwhelmingly the
opposite feeling but at the same level
of tension yeah that's time I [__]
like started like tearing up would you
have felt the same without the shrimps
uh I think I would have felt I would
have known for sure that I was beautiful
as [__] but God damn all the shrooms
you're like yeah the catharsis was like
100 eggs
and then I remember and it wasn't like
yo I got a choreograph to this it was
just more like oh my God this song just
saved me because I was in such [__]
like a darker place right yeah and then
after that it just stuck with me I could
not let go of it like you're like I have
to choreograph to this song I just
created to it after the fact because it
was stuck with me it was like the song
found me to save me in that moment holy
[__] and people a lot of people don't
know that but because you know and fans
of me they're like you know that's like
that's like it's like what he's saying
right like you've been singing hit a key
to something but like do you have the
soul in it yeah and like that [__]
that song gave me my [__] soul back
there's like that that's true though
that that emotion part is so important
right and people can feel it it's
something like that's not very tangible
people just know it right so like even
when people try to sing r b there's
always a stark difference when somebody
has so much soul and somebody's just
singing notes right yep you know what
I'm talking about because you I need to
[__] feel like they're trying to [__]
yeah you're like oh I can feel the
romance oh I could feel that energy it's
not lips because you're trying to make
money off of that because you know what
I'm saying it's like you wrote that
because it came from a real last place
and there's because you were so thirsty
about that so what voicemail did uh Can
You Stand The Rain right it legit sounds
like they're crying throughout that
whole song that was my Breakup Song bro
that [__] right there
Can You Stand The Rain right when that
actually came outside bro I can't stand
the rain
I should be hitting you hard dog I
thought you was talking about Missy
Elliott
who's got the keys to the Jeep
I can't stand I was like I'm sorry
yeah that [__] right there got me
[__] hard dude in two different ways
you know I'm saying let's go mine was
rage against machine know your enemy
that was your breakup song no that
changes now
yeah how did that change your life
because there's a line in that song that
says um
like they talk about teachers and all
these stuff right and they go they are
the ones that teach you to fight you you
know that's that was such a confusing
thing I had to pull out the jacket and I
was like reading it and I was like
teach me to fight me or whatever and
then also they're talking about big
words like in ninth grade I didn't know
what assimilation was I don't know what
you know they were they yell that's out
at the end of the song they'd be like
assimilation whatever whatever and I'm
like man this is a dope beat but I don't
know what these words are I'm stupid and
then when I started looking into it I'm
like oh [__] this is crazy about
brainwashing how government propaganda
what the word propaganda means all that
stuff and then just digging into it was
like
he's a [__] lie oh [__] that did
change his life then yeah oh I could see
that though yeah right oh [__] yeah so
changing this [__] assimilation
simulation changed his life dude mine is
Jill Scott golden
that's a great I don't know what it is
about that song but anytime I hear that
song I'm like dude this is what this
was
which one is that
[Music]
living my life like it's golden living
my life I love that song yeah yeah you
didn't change my life but I just feel I
gotta say though man like not in the in
the in a disrespectful way man but dude
man that's pretty gay man I know and
that's why I feel like I connect to it
that's kind of me I feel like I feel
like I'm in that in a positivity that's
gay bro I feel like a strong powerful
woman is it gay that I loved uh the
album beginning to end
big Willy Style
okay no because I did too no no no no no
no that doesn't help your case though at
all come on okay sorry it is gay but I
did too I Really Love Gaining that's
getting a good way man yeah but is it
gay that I really saw that that dude the
game is always welcome to my end
dude is it is it gay that I like that
song is raining man yes that's way up
there bro no because there's a chance
that's symbolic of something cool it's
raining men uh the way yeah it's Rain
Man song that makes you cry
song that made you cry out of Happiness
not sadness oh dude you know what
there's one it's by Kai
wow it's cold it's called last to know
oh my gosh old school it was on the same
like LP or EP that they had say you'll
stay
do you remember say you'll stay by Kai
yes yes a better classic one I just
don't know your one yeah there was one
there was a like kind of like a B-side
one called last to know and it literally
is just about how like he's the last to
know that his girl doesn't want to be
with him no more and I just imagine that
was also me when I had my breakup
I also
dapping the CD players
I guarantee you if you guys is the queen
then don't stop me now you'll be happy
as a [__] cause I'm done I'm
having a good time having a good time
Unwritten Natasha Bedingfield uh isn't
that like a culture shock thing yeah
well we always joke and laugh and sing
it like we always sing it we laugh about
it I was like staring at the blank page
before you open up the commercial we're
gay we're gay we're gay
[Music]
so close
thank you
foreign